hello internet
i'm back it's the reuben report direct
message
and uh we don't have a shortage of
things to talk about today
all right i'm going with three stories
today uh
our crack team of people we went through
everything we said what is the most
important what is the most relevant what
is
gonna not make people's head explode but
they need to know about
and that's what we chose so the three
stories that we're going to be covering
today you probably
heard obviously that uh supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg
passed away on friday evening um
and you know the way politics are these
days
we don't even wait you know a minute we
don't even wait 30 seconds we don't we
don't wait 10 seconds
uh to start the political fighting of
course
uh and now it appears that trump is
going to nominate
someone to be the next supreme court
judge otherwise we'd have a court
with uh four conservatives basically and
four liberals going into an election
year that
very much seems like it could be
contested and we could have all sorts of
problems
because of that but what i'm going to
focus on
is a little bit of sort of the real
politic about this of sort of why
trump has to do it and the republicans
have to
confirm but also just sort of the
reaction the media reaction the blue
check twitter reaction
and this feeling like that if you don't
get what you want
that you have authority to burn it all
down which has been a sentiment coming
out of the left
for a long time let's not forget that
even in the primaries
uh p bootage uh who was like as vanilla
and boring as
anything you could possibly imagine even
turned to bernie in the last debate that
he was in
and said you want to burn it all down i
don't well i think that burn it all down
sentiment
that the leftists and the socialists and
the marxists and the progressives have
been just
pushing throughout society well then
when something like this happens
uh it just gives them more excuse to to
pour
fuel on the flame but what i will really
really try to do
is try to do this sort of from an
apolitical position and just look at the
reality of the situation
and what every side sort of has to do
the two other stories
that i want to talk about well one of
them we're gonna show you a compilation
of videos from the last couple days
uh from san diego from dc
uh and i forgot where the other one is
we'll check in just a sec but
um the the black lives matter protesters
that are deciding well this sort of fits
the burn it all down thing
uh that they can harass people on the
street
they can harass people at restaurants
they can harass people
at gay bars that they have decided that
whatever their
cause is that their cause is so
righteous
that everyone else must bow to them i'm
sure you guys have seen these clips go
around but the thing is and the reason i
wanted to do this is not just to
is not to outrage you with the awful
things that these people are doing
and that they are making sure that other
people can't live their lives you know
especially
in a time of pandemic when uh people are
getting out less and less
if you if you can't get out or if you go
out and then you're basically assaulted
by people who make you repeat phrases
after them i did that video last week
where they had people repeating phrases
or they won't let your car pass or they
won't let you eat
um well then it's just more of our
social fabric disinterrating
disintegrating so we're going to touch
that and then finally
i'm guessing you might have seen this
clip yesterday but there is something
very weird
going on with the democrats it's not
just joe biden that can't seem to figure
out where he is and there was another
clip yesterday where he was being
interviewed by
somebody i think on abc and at one point
you can see that his teleprompter goes
out so he's not
actually facing the interviewer and i i
i think the interviewer actually and i
believe this is abc
they should have to answer well it was
joe biden talking
to the interviewer was he looking at the
interview and giving answers or was he
getting a question from an interviewer
and then looking away
at a teleprompter because at some point
the teleprompter stops and biden clearly
doesn't know
what he's talking about anymore that's
not even the story we're covering
because those type of glitches
with with biden are happening every two
seconds but nancy pelosi
was on george stephanopoulos's show on
sunday morning
and i don't know what happened her she
had a short circuit
she had a full-on like robotic short
circuit and reset the interview in the
middle
so we're going to show you that clip and
again i'm doing that
not i'm doing that not because it's just
like a like a viral moment as much as
like
what is going on with the people
that govern us what is happening to
these people
and why are there so many old people
breaking down in front of our eyes
perhaps there's a new world and we need
some younger blood involved and i don't
mean to make this about
making fun of old people either i like
old people okay
as you guys know my favorite sitcom of
all time is the golden girls i have
nothing but respect
for people in their golden years but but
perhaps
these people should not be governing us
okay so let's go to the first story so
uh ruth bader ginsburg passing away at
85 from pancreatic cancer on
friday evening now as i said i'm going
to try to do this in a in a non-partisan
way so
first off uh it's been known that she's
been ill for quite some time she had
beat cancer a few times and everything
else so you know
the quote that's being thrown around now
is that her last dying wish
was that she wanted um another president
to replace her or at least get to the
next election that seems to be the the
quote that you know they're saying these
were her last words it sounds like a
little hollywood
dramatic but i do believe that she
probably had the sentiment
that if she was going to pass away that
she didn't want trump to replace her
but realistically if trump was going to
win re-election she
there was virtually no chance with
pancreatic cancer at 85 that she was
going to make it another four years past
trump
so let me just get one thing out of the
way with that i think
that in retrospect perhaps the people
around her
um maybe a year ago should have been
saying you know we don't want
you know the worst to happen right
before the election in light of
everything else that's going on here in
the country
and perhaps you should consider stepping
down now where you might be able
to influence trump or influence the
republicans to sort of guide them to
pick someone that might be a little
more in line excuse me might be a little
more in line
with with your way of thinking or your
your judicial ideology that sort of
thing i think that perhaps would have
been a good idea because
the longer late they let this go with
her and and it was known that she was
sick and i'm not blaming i'm not
certainly not blaming her and i'm not
even blaming anyone around her
again i'm just trying to talk about this
from like the realist perspective the
longer they let this go
they knew that this moment could happen
and i actually wonder what was going on
behind the scenes because let's not
forget
i think the first day that we did this
direct message show two weeks ago
the first story that i covered was that
trump released
his list of 20 nominees for the supreme
court that was sort of
getting ahead of it right like that was
a hint like something could potentially
happen here so maybe there were more
whispers that we know about
that's the type of thing that in dc will
leak and we'll we'll find out more
so that's just one sort of realist
position on this that perhaps
her and her team should have tried to
deal with this a little bit earlier
because now
now we're in a really tough spot because
here's the situation
trump basically has to use the power
that he has
as president to to nominate any
president
would do it any president would be in
their right to do it by the way there's
a clip
floating around of ruth bader ginsburg
being interviewed a couple years ago
talking about how we vote a president
in for four years so he has to do his
job for the duration of the four years
he doesn't just do his job for a third
year on the chance that he might not be
serving the fifth year so her ideology
would have led to trump
nominating somebody that that's just
again that's realist that's a fact
that's not partisan
okay so that's that's one thing uh on
the other side of this
of course is that now what can happen is
that
you may remember in 2013 the democrats
who had a majority blew up the
filibuster this was harry reid's nuclear
option that
to get your justices passed you wouldn't
need that supermajority anymore you
would need a simple majority of 51
senators
now you can find video i don't recommend
you searching
young turks videos for me but you can
find videos of me
as a lefty and as a democrat back in
2013 on the young turks
saying this is a mistake you cannot
think that this will not bite you guys
in the butt and that is exactly what's
happening and by the way
when harry reid blew up the
supermajority he used the nuclear option
that's what they called it you can also
google all this stuff
so that they could just get a justice in
with 51 votes a simple majority
plus right now the tiebreaker of course
is the vice president mike pence and he
happens to be
a republican a conservative so you can
even do it with less than 51
because he becomes the tiebreaker um
i was warning about this because once
you once you
change the rules well you better hope
that you hold on to power forever and
obviously the democrats haven't held on
to power forever and obviously the
republicans aren't going to hold on to
power forever
so you really got to be careful what you
wish for and as a lefty and as a
democrat i was warning them about it
literally seven years ago
so now that's what harry reid decided to
do the democrats decided to do it you
can find all the democrat leadership
saying it was the right thing to do blah
blah blah
and what they have left themselves with
right now is a situation where trump
will nominate right it might come as
early as today
he is going to nominate and in effect
the republicans have the votes because
even mitt romney now
is saying that he's willing uh to take a
vote on a nominee that just happened in
the last
couple hours and he was sort of on the
fence there are two other
republicans that are sort of on the
fence on this but in essence
the republicans basically will have the
numbers and it's unfortunate that all
these votes come down to the
the purely partisan lines on this right
democrats do this republicans do this
but the simple truth is that if you
flipped it the other way both sides
would do it so both people saying oh
they're hypocrites because this is what
they said
a long time ago and they're hypocrites
because this is what they said a long
time ago
that's all irrelevant that's just all
playing politics but but politics is the
game
of power it's game of thrones right what
do i always say about game of thrones
game of thrones
it's a it was a constant quest for power
everyone ends up dead and then there's a
couple people at a table at the end and
everyone they know is dead it's not a
fun game right
and that's why what you can see right
now is that there's a certain set of
people
who are using this to
basically say burn down the system and
they're they're showing you so
they're really showing you how sort of
endlessly
angry and and um
disturbed they are so we're going to
just throw up a couple tweets right now
these are just a random selection of
blue check people on twitter so these
are verified people on twitter
which means they are of some influence
we just we just grabbed a couple
but there was a real sentiment and there
has been a real sentiment over the last
couple days on twitter
that from lefties and democrats that we
should just burn it all down that if
if trump dare does what the constitution
guarantees him the right to do and if
this and if the
senate does what they're supposed to do
that they'll just burn it down
and and there's a real short side in
this uh you may have seen one of the
tweets there was from
reza aslan who uh that guy's a real
piece of work he was the one that
well first off he was the one that was
one of the prime people calling sam
harris a racist
for years and years which was one of the
things that actually caused my
political awakening because sam was just
sort of a moderate
decent liberal and and then here's him
being called a racist by this buffoon
res aslan was also the guy now he's
calling to burn it all down which sort
of sounds like violence
he's also the guy that said that nick
sandman had uh what was it
the most punchable face or something
like that i don't think he deleted
the tweet or maybe he did after the
lawsuits anyway there was a whole slew
of those kind of tweets right
and but it wasn't just sort of random
celebrities and and blue check twitter
it was really coming from mainstream
democrats i mean another sentiment
that was coming from democrats and
kamala harris tweeted about this and aoc
did a little video talking about this is
that trump is ignoring
the dying wishes of this woman
well let's just say her dying wishes
were that she wanted to be replaced by a
different president first off it's not
her seat
right it's it's it's the people's seat
we we own that seat
she was she was in that seat and and
that's great and
and uh and by the way i was actually
pretty enthused
to see that there were no people of
worth of any note that i saw
that were dancing on her grave or happy
that she died or saying anything really
awful about her that's not to say there
was no tweets about that but like
any blue check people anyone of any
influence i saw a lot of people saying i
disagreed with her
judicial decisions particularly her her
stance on abortion
um but you know she was a good person
and a patriot and blah blah blah like
there was very little of the other thing
and
and yet we know whenever a conservative
dies it's ah they're
dancing in hell with hitler and the
whole thing and we get that from
mainstream people
and that is part of the asymmetry that
i've been talking about now for a couple
years about what happens
with people on the left versus people on
the right but anyway aoc and kamala
harris and a bunch of other people
i think chuck schumer chimed in on this
this idea that
it was her wish and and aoc basically
was saying donald trump doesn't care
about the dying wishes
of people and it's like the hypocrisy is
so off the charts it's like
if it was a conservative judge who died
and her
dying wish was to not be replaced by a
democratic president it's like do you
think aoc would be for that it's like
you guys are all playing this
this really silly awful disingenuous
game and i think people can see it
so when i when i talk about this through
a non-political lens what i'm saying is
if if you're in politics and you've got
the power to do something
well then most likely you're going to do
it harry reid did it and he's paying the
consequences
donald trump in this case people didn't
vote donald trump in to not
nominate somebody if he has the power to
do it so he has to do it his own base
would turn on him
but also and this i think is is the part
that people are speaking about the least
and this might be
the most important part of the whole
thing uh we're already being set up so
that
it's like no one's going to accept the
results of election night right we're
going to get in this endless we're going
to either be tied to the electoral
college or they'll say there was
fraudulent voting or whatever it might
be right
we're being set up by the media for this
and by politicians for this well now
let's pretend for a second that the
craziest situation happens
we end up either with a you know go back
to bush and gore situation with hanging
chads and everything else we end up with
some contested election
or even an electoral college tie as
unlikely as that is
we end up in one of those situations and
then it gets all the way to the supreme
court now pretend
for a moment that trump does not
nominate anyone and we end up with
basically four liberals and four
conservatives on the court and then
we get a supreme court decision about
the election
that gets left in a 4-4 tie we would
then be
basically in a constitutional crisis
that that would be almost unimaginable
that i don't think the founders
could have foreseen or even would have
dealt with and then
everything would be off the table the
burn it down people would be so enthused
that we would be in such a
um such a stalemate that god only knows
what they would do
so for no other reason even if you don't
like trump and you don't like
conservative judges and all of those
things if you want
if you basically believe that the system
itself is good which i do think most
people believe
except really for the crazy lefties i
think most people believe the system is
good and most people understand you're
not always going to get what you want
but but the last thing that that anyone
that's in america if you think this
thing is decent should want is somehow
some kind of contested election that
gets to a court
that then is hung up because then we are
we have two branches of government that
basically can't function and it's not
like
that third branch of government uh it's
not like the the senate and the congress
are doing such a great job
over there are functioning so anyway
we've got a whole bunch of things going
on
i i would say more than anything else uh
put the burn it all down people aside
and put sort of you know there's also
this like never trump
side of this which is i saw that david
french and jonah goldberg wrote a piece
that the republicans
should promise to delay the nomination
trump should delay the nomination so
that in exchange the democrats
will promise not to pack the court if
they get power promise not to expand the
court
and it's like these ideas they're just
like man
you guys don't understand what politics
is you don't first off no promise means
anything like
these are just childhood childish sort
of intellectual think peace games but
that people i guess take somewhat
seriously but these are silly ideas so
look i i hope
that if the if the shoe was on the other
foot if all of this was reversed by
party i would be saying the exact same
thing i hope that is the case i think it
is the case
but the simple reality like the brass
tax on this is trump's got the power to
do it
he's gonna do it he's got to do it and
the senate has to vote
and and let's just not forget how insane
this was with brett kavanaugh that the
guy basically was a gang rapist
and it's like he's been a pretty decent
judge now for two years and
we just move on past all that so anyway
it's not going to calm down we didn't
need more fuel to the fire it ain't
going to calm down anytime soon but
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
framework to talk about this stuff with
with your friends and family
without going totally crazy uh but
speaking of totally crazy
uh we're going to show you now a
compilation of three videos
from the last couple days that involve
black lives matter
and antifa protesters and as i said in
the intro
one of the things that's happening right
now is we're watching the disintegration
of all of our public spaces that we've
just decided for some reason
mostly in democratic-run cities we've
decided to let
a group of thugs and i would argue in
effect domestic terrorists
to just do whatever they want whenever
they want so we're going to show you
three
videos one is at a restaurant in san
diego they're harassing people another
one is stopping
traffic and demanding people say what
you want them to say
uh and uh the third one is a really
interesting one at a dc gay bar and then
i'll
i'll kind of catch you up on my thoughts
you're all stolen wow
[Music]
yeah say black lives matter huh say
[ __ ] black lives matter right now
black lives matter
say black lives matter bro
you didn't i didn't hear [ __ ] bro okay
sorry are you even proud
let them talk let them talk thank you
all right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] then keep then be embarrassed
all right so as you can see i think
uh these people these protesters they
think they're the good guys
and uh i say it 27 times a week
but the road to hell is paved with good
intentions i believe that most of these
people their intentions are good
their minds have been so muddled with
critical race
theory and cultural marxism and the rest
of this lefty nonsense
that they actually think they're the
good people they think that they have
the moral right and duty
to walk up to people at restaurants and
harass them because they might
they might have different political
beliefs for all they know these people
support them
well they don't support them anymore and
i think these people are are making
trump supporters that they're like
throwing gremlins into the water to to
multiply trump supporters because i
think every time you do this
the average person goes okay well if i
can't go out to the restaurant anymore
because i'm going to be
harassed by black lives matter people
and trump's the only ones speaking out
against it because obviously no democrat
will
well then i'll vote for trump so
congratulations on that to the blm
antifa crew uh but you know you're
harassing people at restaurants then
the one with the the middle video that
we showed you there where they're
stopping traffic and demanding people
do what they want i mean ju put aside
politics for a second
imagine if this was you imagine if
forget you
imagine if this was your mom imagine if
this was your grandma she's driving down
the street
and then a bunch of people stop her car
and force her to do something
whatever it might be bow to their
commands get out of the car they're
there
i could have showed you plenty of other
videos that happened this weekend where
they're they're bashing in this
uh guy's car his dog's in the car it
turns out he was there to support black
lives matter like
it's just an endless cascade of of
lunacy and nonsense
but the point is that what we're
watching in these videos isn't just that
these people are crazy
it's that where is civil society like
where
are the police and i don't blame the
police by the way because in many of
these cases their their democrat usually
runs cities where the the mayors are not
backing the police
right so and we've got calls to defund
the police
if we don't have basic civility in
society then we don't have much else
that kind of brings me to the third one
which i think was the most interesting
one so the third
one was at a dc gay bar and what you can
see is this girl
screaming at this man he's at a gay bar
so i assume he's gay let's assume this
guy is gay
and what this shows you is how out of
whack
the whole intersectional calculator is
so for those of you that are that are
just getting caught up on all this
one of the things the left has created
is a hierarchy of oppression olympics
and depending on how oppressed you are
you are worth more in in that pyramid
picture it this way right so at the
bottom the most worthless
is the straight white christian male
because they're privileged and they
should
be treated the worst so they have sort
of no value to society
then you could kind of throw like asians
and jews in there because they're sort
of minorities except they've succeeded
so they don't really count as anything
and then you can sort of build up so
like you maybe have latinos here
and gay people here but gay people if
you're gay and white and a male like
this guy then you kind of move down
because you know we've got latinx
lesbians
with lazy eyes who should be here and
then black people here and muslims here
and it's
it creates this insane system of
competing interests
which are based on characteristics that
none of us would want to be judged by
but what's interesting about this video
is it shows you why the thing
doesn't work it does not work and why
does it not work well
i don't know what that man's political
beliefs are
you would think though if we're we're
told that gay people are supposed to all
be lefties right even though i just saw
a poll there's a really interesting poll
out right now that's showing that 45
of gay men are going to vote for trump
which is actually pretty
pretty interesting but putting that
aside for a second we're told that
the lefties the intersectional marxists
that they care about gay people
so why are they marching up to gay bars
and demanding
that gay men bow to them gay men and i
assume there were some
there's some lesbians there there's
always one lesbian there uh i assume
that the lesbian
and the gay men that they're supposed to
supposed to bow to these people
and it's like your calculator is out of
whack nobody has to bow to anybody these
these are bad people it's just it's just
a freaking it's just a freaking mess and
we're just going to see more and more of
these videos and i'm going to try not to
outrage you with them
but i do think it's important that you
guys see some of them because they won't
show them on cnn
right they're not going to show them on
cnn unless it's a trump supporter
punching somebody which pretty much
never happens
okay i want to show you one other thing
that happened that i think is worth
showing because it gets to the sort of
heart of what is going on with the
democrats which nobody fully understands
but nancy pelosi was on george
stephanopoulos's
show on sunday morning and she had a
system malfunction 10 states as i said
on friday i started their early voting
the day that we lost ruth bader ginsburg
but to be clear you're not taking any
arrows out of your quiver you're not
ruling anything out
good morning sunday morning
the uh we have a responsibility
we take an oath to protect and defend
the constitution
of the united states what happened there
what happened what happened now i get
people were saying well something
happened to her teleprompter or
something else
now this is in the middle of a
conversation that is not edited by the
way i watched the full clip you can
watch the full
you know seven or eight minute interview
on youtube so it's fully there this is
not selectively edited or anything else
like that
people are saying maybe her ifb that's
the the earpiece that you have
that that freaked out or something else
but she knew she was in the middle of an
interview
something's not right with these people
okay i keep saying that with biden the
scandal is the non-scandal
the scandal is not that biden has
dementia and there is obviously
something wrong with him okay
or dementia or something like that uh
that's not the scandal the scandal is
that
everybody knows everyone around him
knows the media knows
and everyone's afraid of touching it and
as i've been saying
when it breaks whether it's after he
loses or after he wins or right before
or when he steps down whatever it might
be
they're all going to turn on each other
because everyone's going to want to
protect their butt
and be like oh no no i wanted to say
something
but i didn't but but really think about
it this way if you're hillary clinton i
said this last week if you're hillary
clinton you're barack obama or whoever
the
the the power people are in the party
you're complicit right now you're
complicit in the fact that these clips
keep coming out of iden but
but i showed you this nancy pelosi one
because it's like what the high hell is
going on with her put him inside the
the the eyebrows which should be studied
by
scientists for the rest of time um
like did she have some sort of like
little mental snap there
um i don't think that that is what
happens because of
you know you could have whatever you
have on a teleprompter right a
teleprompter is just
throwing words in front of you and maybe
it has the question so you can fully
answer it but you wouldn't
you wouldn't know where you wouldn't
completely lose your
your place in the conversation you
wouldn't be saying in effect good
morning
again in the middle of a conversation
like it just doesn't make sense so i
don't know what's going on there
but again that's the type of clip that
you're not going to see that on cnn and
you ain't going to see it on msnbc
had it been trump people you would so i
think what i'm trying to do a little bit
with this show is just get us to a
little bit
of more of an even keeled reset on
things anyway so what you got there
people today was a little bit of real
politics on the ruth bader
ginsburg situation you got a little bit
of uh
let's not burn the whole freaking down
thing down with the blm and antifa thing
and then you got our politicians are
literally breaking down in front of us
and they all need a software patch
because things aren't right that was the
reuben report direct message
we'll be back tomorrow
you